hey idris how you doing logan how are
you i'm good thanks i am great well i
just talked to your lovely co-stars
ayanna and leah and they said they had
so much fun with you on set you tried
cooking behind the scenes rapping on set
what was it like working with them
it was a lot of fun you know i became
their off-screen and on-screen father
you know what i'm saying and i they were
hard on me so i had to try and keep them
on my side it was good though but
they're really great pros um i really
fell in love with them and hopefully
them with me and you know i couldn't
have asked for a better team
how were they hard on you
um
you know if i try to say something funny
they'll be like
that ain't funny
you're gonna make us laugh now like you
know like you know and then
leah was always trying to get me to do
some crazy tick-tock dance
ah
and she's like come on mr elba
come on mr elva i love that so much
listen there are so many great movies
out right now you've got jamie foxx
hunting vampires you have daniel kaluya
hunting down aliens you're fighting
lions how does it feel to be part of
this amazing group of people as these
action heroes right now in hollywood oh
wow that's a great question i mean it's
a great you know sign of the times that
you know we have some diversity in the
types of films and you know actors black
actors getting a you know that sort of
role it's a great great time i i will
say that my character is definitely no
action hero in this film he's uh he's a
dad you know what i mean he's just
trying to fight for his kids
uh but i will say like like you say you
know both daniel and jamie
foxx you know have such incredible up um
careers
it's great to have you know
three films that have this sort of span
it's amazing it's so amazing um you and
sabrina are a couple goals i saw you at
the premiere of this film how did she
handle it because i was squirming
watching this movie
she had a heart on her heart in her
mouth she uh she loves movies like this
and she just was like whoa that was a
ride and you know i was sitting next to
her in the premiere and she was like oh
my god what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen i'm like i can't tell you what's
gonna happen you're in the movies
oh that must have been fun for you to
see that
yeah it was good it was good that's
awesome what was it about this script
that you knew you wanted to be a part of
um look it's complex because you know
this isn't an action hero this is a dad
and this is a thriller this is a real
like you know
how ketchum thriller and having a film
that has both the heart
and the action
in symmetry is is difficult you know
people just want to see fighting they
don't really care about the backstory
but and there's i think there's a little
bit of a blend of it and i'm hoping that
you know the audience kind of relate to
it like you want them to survive at the
end of this film because you care about
them
that's what i was saying to your
co-stars i said from the beginning i
felt emotionally connected so you're
rooting for them the whole way through
and listen i don't want to ruin anything
but that that
scene at the end where you face off with
a lion i wasn't sure what was going to
happen
it was so good
i appreciate that but you know if
anybody faces off with a lion you know
it's gonna happen that's true
um you have teased that you are working
on this big dc project obviously i'm not
gonna ask you anything about it however
when it comes to the dc properties
how much fun would it be if you got the
chance to go up against jason momoa as
aquaman i'm just saying i'm just
throwing it out there what do you put it
out put it out there look i really
believe and
as much as i i've sort of teased this
idea and i haven't really teased that i
just would love to see my character come
back
um and i've definitely said that to the
higher-ups so you know there's things
that we can see in the future obviously
is a friend of mine he's a big character
in the dc world
absolutely let's get it going you know
what i mean
go from lion to fish i don't know
no this actually now needs to happen if
you think it's a good idea i feel like
it's going to happen a dress boy oh i
think you you know you have a way of
manifesting things you put it out there
i've got you uh congratulations on this
movie uh it was such a wild ride you're
so good in this
i appreciate it it's good to see you
again
thank you